bonjour brut/mois sénégal on va parler
écologie et planète ensemble comment
s'est passé votre prise de conscience
alors lorsque l'on est au bord de la
méditerranée qui ont grandi au bord de
la méditerranée
vous avez assez rapidement une
conscience sur l'importance de la nature
sur le fait qu'il faille ramasser des
les sacs en plastique ou les ou les
papiers qui emballe les pans bagnats
extrêmement rapidement donc je pense que
j'ai toujours tout le temps grandi avec
cette notion de si on aime un endroit on
ramasse les déchets que l'on a causé ça
a été toujours toujours toujours été un
déclic pour moi et puis ensuite le le le
choc ce sont les premières les premières
images
les docks sur nés de fixe où on se dit
c'est pas possible de voir la banquise
s'écrouler comme ça c'est pas possible
de voir des forêts entières brûlé pour
planter du soja c'est pas possible de
voir des continent de plastique
d'acheter un moment d'autant qu'ils
seront plutôt récent mais tout a
commencé bizarrement par des images de
l214 sur la souffrance animale et ce qui
en découle et ensuite c'est à dire la
masse d'eau nécessaire pour le moindre
steak puis l'élevage intensif les
cultures de soja et les forêts l'huile
de palme et tout et tout et saloperies
et tout va extrêmement extrêmement vite
ensuite
et quand vous voyez à une vache suspendu
par la patte arrière une patte arrière
et qui est en train de se débattre et qu
on la tue avec une espèce de pistolets
électromagnétiques ou est con on est con
les gorges pour que le sang coule
ouais rien il ya un moment où on se dit
j'ai pas envie de d'être complice de ça
quand vous entendez un vous hurlez en
parce qu'on arrache sa mère qui l'a 4 5
mois et que c'est qu'il est propre à la
consommation
on n'a pas envie d'être complice de ça
en moi je n'ai pas envie d'être complice
de ça ça a été un détonateur pour moi
dans la la la la consommation déjà de
viande mais c'est intimement lié avec le
respect de la planète pour moi et s'il
ya un nom qui vous a fait basculer en
dix ans et aujourd'hui je vais justement
mettre mes actions en conséquence le
camp vous voyez toutes ces images quand
vous êtes conscient de votre impact sur
la planète est de votre responsabilité
versus parents de quatre enfants
ouais on se dit que à défaut d'agir
à un niveau mondial en étant responsable
d'une association ou ou en emportant des
messages ou une parole on a une
responsabilité en tant que père de
famille et en tant que citoyen est
justement parlé que vous êtes père de
famille et c'est justement ça un rôle
particulier dans votre engagement vous
sentez particulière c'est évident c'est
évident c'est évident qu'il faut un papa
doit doit acheter des gourdes en disant
à ses enfants va n'y a plus de
bouteilles en plastique maintenant vous
avez des gourous de et remplir point on
doit commencer par des le tri sélectif à
la maison évidemment on doit commencer
par les les dentifrices va commencer
donc ça c'est la dernière nouveauté sont
les dentifrices avec des recharges
dentifrice solide base de charbon de
citron et de
et demander le montant vers le zéro
déchet il moi j'ai grandi avec une
génération d'après-guerre qui était on
ne gaspille pas on finit son assiette
quoi qu'il arrive je pense que
maintenant on est arrivé à une
génération où on ne met dans l'assiette
que ce dont on a réellement besoin
on va pas se forcer à finir l'assiette
puisqu'il y en aura pas trop et on aura
acheté le strict minimum
je pense que c'est bien aussi que dans
le frigo y ait des produits frais mais
que ce soit les produits qui servent
dans les dans les 24 48 heures ça sert à
rien de faire quand on le peut
évidemment une fois les courses pour la
semaine ou pour le mois tout ça emballé
à à outrance et on voit au fur et à
mesure comment on consomme que ce soit
ma femme moment là totalement éliminé
viande de poisson les oeufs le laitage
de vaches et pour ce qui est des enfants
on dose encore un tout petit peu en
fonction de leur demande discrètement de
temps en temps on glisse à un steak vdj
ils s'en rendent pas compte il ne trouve
super bon et c'est seulement après qu'on
leur dit il et pas de viande dans le
dans votre burger végétarien mais ça
sera évidemment de décider ça c'est
vraiment le mode de consommation à la
maison je rêve et c'est pas possible
parce qu'il y ait des problèmes de
syndics de copropriété de mérimée
d'avoir des panneaux solaires à paris de
pouvoir être aussi dans une
autosuffisance énergétique ensuite dans
la boîte de prod ben pareil c'est à dire
qu'on a été le café en capsules et c'est
bien de le bouder c'est bien de le
consommer tel quel sans qu'il y ait de
de déchets aluminium rajouter il ya des
gourdes et des bonbonnes à eau ou de
l'eau du robinet partout j'ai supprimé
la viande sur les sur les quatre ring ce
que lorsqu'on mange sur les sur les
tournages dans les émissions que ce soit
inter ou c zéro plastique
c'est une décision prise par parfois la
direction de france inter mais on est
avec soin la carafe d'eau et le gobelet
en papier soit chacun sa gourde sur les
tournages télé aussi des gourdes pour
eux tous des membres de l'équipe et des
gobelets pour les personnes du public et
on essaye de responsabiliser le plus
possible le comportement de chacun après
je je je sais que ma situation de bobo
parigot nantis est extrêmement
confortable et et
c'est facile on cherche pas à donner la
leçon mais se dire à notre niveau
si on peut faire quelque chose c'est
déjà ça c'est l'histoire du colibri avec
la petite goutte d'eau qui vient pour
éteindre la forêt voyant lui ça sert à
rien une goutte d'eau j'ai fait ma part
voilà donc je me dis je fais ma part en
ça fait deux ans que j'ai plus acheter
un seul un seul fringues aco d'état
selon très clair jeu j'en avais déjà
trop avant au moment prête pour pour
m'habiller à la télé mais il n'empêche
que je continue d'avoir le réflexe
d'acheter le dernier t-shirt avec tel
logo tel truc
tel père de pau b ainsi de suite c'est
plus le cas maintenant je recycle en
remettant des des vêtements d'ilya d'il
ya 2 3 ans et ça va quoi et tout va bien
[Musique]